oh it's a super trophy yeah yeah and it
does another head coach oh wow they will
be opening some presents on the
information and the presents are I'm new
acosta stuff to make the phone never
make a present come oh my god I need
some people I'll be openers I can't just
open this oversized box by myself all
right look at all this let's start
opening some presents here this one
first this one edify okay go open music
West music Weston get married music West
is an awesome app for kids learn how to
play music you got some stickers thanks
Adrian Adrian you can't read your
handwriting thanks for being some of the
very first people to test music quest
your video is extremely valuable we hope
you like these stickers thanks adrian i
love it this is from static chaos
apparel chaos chaos he just started xk
casa pero I'm a Taurus that's my sign
look at that Oh starter chaos thank you
kindly oh okay what's next
yes okay Orion holiday I just came back
from meeting Ryan in New York Oh his new
book ego is the enemy super excited to
read this Thank You Ryan I don't think
it's out yet but supposed to be released
yeah unconnected proof limited edition
many years in the pre-release version of
it looking for we're gonna cut some
evening reading radius it's a super
trophy 2xl shirt are you kidding me a 2x
do I look like a 2xl Oh a cow this is
the own a go fly drone the cool thing on
this is it has GPS sensor so as you walk
it can follow along except the tested
thank you Oh nah go this one actually
bought myself triggers it's about habits
and routine and creating behaviors at
last I was at a bookstore and kind of
browse through it and was super curious
about it so looking forward to reading
it this is by Marshall Goldsmith
triggers I'm excited what's next
benevolence supply benevolence supplies
started by guiding mo the stock pot that
I beat you before and the rebel t shirt
that I wore before whateva supply has
some new hats and this is the first one
oh I like this look at the packaging
whoo that's some serious packaging oh
it's comfortable we believe that's a
good start a good heart is the most
fashionable accessory of all good heart
goes with almost any everything into
everybody a good heart is perfect for
every season never goes out of fashion
from the heart of LA well done though
super proud of you man this is good
stuff same guy mo number two all of this
one same benevolence in the front just
different styles next one the rebus box
from john saxon in in la em a oh all
right what do we have but is this coffee
oh it's okay we succeed you're Pete the
best investments you can make in
yourself I believe this is one of the
monthly subscriptions right so you can
get a monthly box of stuff to make you a
better person so we've got atomic coffee
house blend nice milk chocolate nutty
tones we got some tazo tea a wig English
breakfast we have some books who is that
are bound nicely here start with why
simon Sinek to take notes notepad
a new pen take notes with their message
here is we succeed repeat success
knowledge in a realist box so you can
get your monthly package through that
okay last one you ready yeah is this
some sleep and beyond sleeping beyond
like no other bedding in the world we
got some bedding from seeping beyond
much love guys so we got hold on malaga
by what is this oh this is some kind of
liquid we got some wooly pillow and
ultimate one hundred percent natural
pillow oh I am The King you are the
Queen we seek like babies in between
this is the sheet set purity by curing
organic hyper allergenic 400 thread
count one hundred percent cotton sateen
that is what set team there's this up I
like the vibe to this is nice then we've
got sheets my here free stock sheets
cool awesome oh this is huge like the
other frame in the world this is a
mattress topper and I just topic welcome
to our family I like your welcome to
your friend oh there's another one
there's something else in there there's
two toppers Oh for once I baby oh thank
you get it we flipped hit it up put it
inside it's a sheep let me see it's a
sheep oh it's a keychain that assess if
you like the best is the big box
all right I'll open up the drone there
we go hi a little bit Jonas it's
controllable ah you gotta love that now
go out please connect your camera
alright so looks like i have to charge
this thing and then we'll be able to
shout again all rights I figured it out
it doesn't the initial charge just has
this has a slot here they got to open up
and pull these wires out and then
connect them which is actually a little
bit awkward in the design to pull those
out but I did it and then it beeps when
you've done it and after after every
flight you've got to disconnect these
two things or causes harm to the battery
let's pop it in here the beep ok so far
so good we got navigation here we got
navigation let's try it
this is very scary that was that was
crazy that was crazy yeah we broke this
propeller broke the propeller it's super
cool and it films I got to figure that
part out but it's not user-friendly way
I see the camera there facto got rocky
boots it's a learning curve but we'll
figure it out thank you and I go okay I
knew the test is up I feel like it's
going to take some time okay we're going
to try it again i'm outside this time it
said make sure there's nothing around
you so that i can get hit which is
better roads but it's also said make
sure it's not windy which it is windy
outside so probably not great but you
know i just want to try it so i might
ruin it again we'll see what happens
okay and Devin Devin Devin Devin Devin
Devin ah I sit down why don't you go
down holy Carol this thing all right I
gotta feel with this GPS abnormalities
is second flight not a success at least
we did not break it so that's a success
thank you guys we're going to link up
all the websites everybody who gave us
this stuff if you guys want to send us
anything we'll link up the address as
well description and maybe you will be
featured and your product on the next
edition of mail time with Evan Hayden
and Nina so thank you guys for watching
have an amazing weekend continue to
believe I will see you soon